(curious music)
- [Narrator] These images
show Russia's Black Sea
Fleet headquarters in Crimea
before and after an
attack on September 22nd.
(explosion booms)
The strike killed and injured dozens
including senior leaders of the Navy,
according to Kyiv.
(explosion booms)
Another attack on Russia's
principal dry dock
in the city of Sevastopol in mid-September
destroyed a large landing ship
and heavily damaged a submarine.
- Ukraine has shown that it's
not only on the receiving end,
it can attack Russia in return.
- [Narrator] The assaults are
part of a Ukrainian strategy
to weaken military and
logistics facilities
on the occupied peninsula.
- Ukraine wants to cut off Crimea
to make the peninsula untenable.
- [Narrator] Here's why Ukraine
has ramped up its attacks
on the peninsula.
(tense music)
Crimea is crucial for Russia's
operations in Ukraine.
It's a supply hub for Russian forces
resisting Ukraine's counter offensive
which started in summer 2023.
- Most important fighting
is happening in the southeast of Ukraine.
Russian troops there are
being supplied from Crimea,
so that's incredibly
important in particular
because the supply from
the east is not as strong.
- [Narrator] Russia has
also turned the peninsula
into a heavily militarized zone
since the annexation in 2014.
Sevastopol is the home of
Russia's Black Sea Fleet,
where some of the country's
most sophisticated warships
are stationed.
(missile whooshing)
- One way that Black
Sea Fleet has been used
as a way to launch cruise
missiles that have struck military
and civilian infrastructure
targets within Ukraine.
- [Narrator] There are also several
important military air bases,
some of which Ukraine has
targeted since last year
To protect its assets,
Russia has stationed
their air defense systems
across the peninsula.
In September, Ukraine said it destroyed
a sophisticated air defense
system known as the S-400.
- The Ukrainians say
that they sent in drones
to attack the S-400's radars.
(explosives crackling)
They used two Neptune missiles
that were made by the Ukrainians
and that they destroyed this S-400 system.
- [Narrator] Ukraine
has intensified attacks
on the occupied peninsula in recent months
as its ability to target Crimea improved.
- Ukraine has gotten cruise missiles
from Britain and France.
They've also developed their own weapons
that they've been able to use,
drones, torpedoes,
and the Ukrainians have figured out
how to orchestrate very
complicated attacks.
- [Narrator] Russia acknowledged
that two of its warships
had been struck in Sevastopol
and one service member was missing
after the attack on the Navy headquarters,
but it didn't confirm any damage
to its air defense systems.
As winter approaches,
Kyiv is trying to neutralize the threats
that Russia's military
assets in Crimea posed
to Ukraine's critical infrastructure.
- Ukraine would like
not only to continue
these attacks on Crimea
but also to ramp them up.
A key part of that is
about getting supplies
of more long range missiles
and longer range missiles from the west.
The numbers of cruise missiles
from the UK and from France are limited.
They're producing their own
Neptune cruise missiles,
but it's not clear
how many of those they're able to produce.
- [Narrator] In September,
the White House told Ukraine
it would send advanced long
range surface-to-air missiles,
according to US officials.
(missile whooshes)
The new missiles would add to
Ukraine's ability to launch
longer range strikes,
turning Crimea into an
even more dangerous place
for Russian troops.